Peterson gives fans a way of feeling
smart without actually having to
thoroughly study the intellectuals that
Peterson cites much less the countless
philosophers with viewpoints that
directly contradict Peterson in really
credible and important ways being a
loyal on questioning Peterson fan
doesn't really demand much of you right
it's easy many in Peterson's audience
are relying on his interpretations and
his conclusions about philosophical
issues in current events without doing
much thinking on their own and that's
what gurus do and enable their followers
to do being Guided by an Eclectic mix of
thinkers and ideologies might be more
confusing it'll definitely be less
straightforward it will be more Messy as
I like to say it will require you to
sort things out for yourself instead of
having your world view spoon fed to you
by one person
but that's what it means to be a free
and critical thinker and that's why I
encourage you to do it